[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm red and I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we got to address some
voicemails I mean you know we put our
number out there 1888 earpod one and of
course we put your voicemails at the end
of episodes but
we we just thought it was necessary to
start addressing some of these directly
so we're going to be doing that today
we're also going to be talking uh a
little bit about the cereal that we've
developed and what is that like we'll
tell you like the actual development
process it's actually more interesting
than you might first think when you
think about serial development and if
it's not going to take a class in seral
call us and let us know that it wasn't
interesting if you take a class in
serial development you might be like oh
yeah I've got serial development at 9:00
a.m. on
Mondays well we're going to be the most
interesting serial development
professors you've ever
had okay let's hear a
voicemail Rhett oh my gosh you talking
about mixing oatmeal and yogurt you say
it needs to be a thing it is already a
thing it's called Swedish oatmeal you
just take the oats and mix them directly
in the yogurt add whatever kind of
fruits nuts seeds that you want to it
put it in the fridge let it sit
overnight and then the oats soak up all
that yogurt and you get all the good
benefits from it especially when you add
stuff like chia seeds and pumpkin seeds
and stuff like that as well so just a
recommendation for you guys try that out
you will love it
okay uh a I'm not Swedish I'm often
mistaken for being Swedish I'm not just
because I'm tall and have hints of
blonde doesn't mean I'm Swedish two
thank you for
that uh yeah well as we discovered on as
we discovered on the show
um people had already not only discover
that you could do it uh but now I guess
it was already a thing and that's
Technic not what I did it actually
sounds it sounds it sounds better than
what I did she's describing I put a
dollop of yogurt in oatmeal yeah she's
describing overnight Yol meal
yolt yeah y yeah overnight oats with a
yogurt have you done it more though uh
because and does anybody call it Yol
meal I only do it at airports can't you
give the guy just give him just give him
a little discover well here's the thing
I think here's the thing I think this is
sent me into a bit not a full
existential crisis uh but you
know when I thought that I had invented
something yeah I was super happy now I
suspect you were strutting around say
yal now when I was in the airport and I
put some oatmeal some yogurt into my
oatmeal I thought well I can't be the
first guy to do this I mean it's
probably happened at least on accident a
million times yeah you know what I'm
saying if you got yogurt and you got
oatmeal they're going to
mix but when I thought that I had come
up with something novel that I never
heard of I felt happy and then when I
discovered that a lot of people had
already discovered it you know I I felt
like uh uh you know I'm not going to use
a Columbus analogy
here because that would be insensitive
and wrong um because I just we're just
talking about food here we're not
talking about like exploiting an entire
culture or anything like I hope not uh
but I realized I did not
discover America and I did not discover
Yol meal and I am I am intrigued by this
but it sounds like it I don't know it
sounds like quite a process I'm just
talking about being in an airport Buffet
yeah essentially and grabbing it's
different you discovered something
different man yeah I think you could
probably be also be done at
hotels yeah a kind of little continental
breakfast I'm honestly not planning on
doing it at home I don't know
why is you're you're too good for it no
it's not good enough for you no it I it
was invented by someone else you of all
people should know that you're Columbus
you you of all people should know that
you're exploting people I'm trying to do
like treat myself in a certain
environment this is a very but first of
all a very link thing
to I'm not going to do this in this
environment I'm going to do it in this
environment so I look forward to that
like you can look forward to traveling
right it's like oh did you enjoy your
trip yes I started it with some Yol meal
and it was all downhill from there I
can't wait to go on another Yol meal
Adventure what is that oh that's just
when I travel a travel but I eat some
Yol meal or if I stop at a motel I've
never heard the term and no one's saying
oh yeah the term Yol meal is is
everywhere all about that's part that's
really missing in all this is that the
mark with the name the marketing and
that's what m we didn't invent cereal
but we invented our cereal mish mash
there you go mish mash could be said
either
way I still have not had any of your Yol
meal but well it's not really mine I
mean you know I didn't I'm not
responsible for the making of the
oatmeal or the yogurt in the scenario
where I had it but that is what I was
referring to when we were talking about
the oatmeal we're like we got we got
something that we're developing it was
the cereal I I remember now that that's
what I was oh you teased that at that I
was teasing it at that point I don't
know um let's play another
voicemail hi Rett link um I'm gonna stay
Anonymous for this one but I've been
with my boyfriend five years in December
and I just want to let you guys know
that early on in our relationship I
disclosed to him that oh I love Rett and
Link so we watched a lot of you guys and
uh you guys would be in the background
how we would have sex
yeah do that what you will come
again I mean literally we would be in
the background when you had
sex okay well stink making them horny
yeah well there's not a lot of stink
coming off of GMM well you know it's
a to some people um how do how do we
process
this
okay
uh I mean honestly I'm looking for more
details uh especially we were in the
background don't you remember especially
since you remained Anonymous did we
enhance I feel like we were like when
she says you guys were in the background
it's like we were like voyur we were
like watching we like peeking over the
edge of the mattress don't say we don't
say when you talk about being in the
corner while someone else is having sex
and peeking at them that's your thing
you said that well no it's not my thing
I never said it was my thing it's not my
thing you brought it up what what you
say you know what you're Christopher
Columbus you brought it up what I'm
saying is is that my understanding is
that we were just doing our show they
made the decision to turn it on while
they were copulating yes I wasn't peing
at anything on I didn't even know it was
happening so the story in your mind it
sounds like you want to be in the room
while a couple is having sex Jerry fwell
Jerry fwell Jr much Liberty you shout
out to Liberty you what Hey listen no to
that I'm just saying that you and your
Miami pool boy we were on in the
background it was like we were is that
like we're standing in the background
lurking no you know that's what you want
it to
be I mean I'm not getting on that train
with you if when she says that she puts
us on a screen and has sex to us the
first thing say that the first thing I
think is not what I'm doing she said we
were on in the background not they
started having sex and then they you
know what let's pause a second let's put
on GMM I don't think that's the order it
happened the thing that I was wondering
about was not whether or not we were
there peing at them is whether or not
they're looking at us while they're
having sex of course they are but we're
in the background I want to know if this
couple is making eye contact with either
of us sometimes the background becomes
foreground while they're having sex
because sometimes if I make eye contact
with my dog during sex I'll just go limp
like that you know what I'm saying I
don't like my dogs to be in the they're
in the room sometimes but we put them in
a we put them in their crate they're in
the background they're but we put them
in the crate don't keep them in the bed
are they talking are they eating food
are they making dumb jokes well but just
sometimes you'll just look over and like
Shawn will have his little snout like
through one of the holes in the crate
just kind of like looking like I'm sad
let me back into bed and it's just like
I see that and I'm in you know I'm a I'm
a sex machine and then all of a sudden
I'm looking at my dog it's like and I'm
that's the only thing I can think about
is the fact that this person is
copulating and then hearing us talk
about like first of all hearing our
chewing which 90% of the show is just
smacking noises at this point is that is
that sexy I don't think so yes I do I do
actually the more I think about it if
you heard a chewing and you didn't know
what it was while you were having sex it
might sound
sexy stop it stop it stop
it now first of all my dogs know to look
away you've you've trained them that's
the one thing you've got in your dogs to
do is to look away while you have sex no
they just know to look away man they
know to look away they Sean I don't
think Sean can see they bury their
noses they know
they can they they know when something
hanking and Panky in his Barbara doesn't
look bar knows Bar's smart Sean's not
smart he's just like when am I going to
get out of here what are y'all
doing it's a fun
anymore you know what're we're
honored
say that's why I said it we are honored
to be uh a part of the festivities in a
passive non-
lurking non- peaking way yeah non
Columbus uh if if we're what it takes to
get you there as a couple um we're happy
to be of service I would just say don't
become dependent on us you know some
people can do things in their
environment where they begin to need
those things in their environment in
order to complete the act and I would
just say um I mean we have no plans to
stop the show at any time in the near
future and I guess you could always
watch reruns if we did
but you know what if the power goes out
your phone's dead you don't have
internet right you still need to be able
to sex you need to be able to have sex
without us being present that's all I'm
saying that's just so maybe every once
in a while do it without us now the
other part of this is that we become a a
horny trigger for this couple pavlovian
you might say So speaking of dogs you
know you come come home from some
errands and GMM is on oh every day every
day we're it's like maybe what if you
what if you stumbled Upon Us in public I
mean what's that going to be like that's
going to be weird for you that's going
to be weird for us and you will not ask
I for one will not peek at you Lincoln
speak for himself yes I can I won't
either okay
good gracious see these voice you know
the things you guys tell us like Bring
it on Bring It On keep calling us I I I
enjoy learning stuff that I didn't know
that now is going to impact my
performance on my show I'm not going to
be thinking about it I'm only going to
be thinking about think about is anybody
sorting the mail doing the dirty getting
the hanky and the Panky I'll freeze up
I'll freeze up if I start thinking about
that if I start thinking about people
having sex while I'm doing my job I
won't be able to do my
job in fact I'm going to have a
difficult time next episode it's okay I
think I I'll be better because of it
okay all right well it all balances out
yeah your biscuits is supported by
indeed hiring can be a challenge but a
little challenge can be a good thing you
need a hiring partner that can help you
rise to that challenge you need indeed
indeed is the hiring platform where you
can attract interview and hire all in
one place instead of spending hours on
multiple job sites searching for
candidates with the right skills
indeed's a powerful hiring platform that
can help you do it all with instant
match over 80% of employers get quality
candidates whose resume on indeed
matches their job description the moment
they sponsor a job according to indeed
data us indeed is great because they do
the hard work for you hiring can be done
all in one place candidates you invite
to apply are three times more likely to
apply to your job than candidates who
only see it in a search according to us
ND data join the more than 3 million
businesses worldwide that use indeed to
hire great Talent fast start hiring now
with a $75 sponsored job credit to
upgrade your job post at
indeed.com offer good for limited time
claim your $75 credit now at
indeed.com that's ear with an S just go
to
indeed.com and support the show by
saying you heard it on this podcast
indeed.com terms and conditions apply
need to hire you need indeed ear
biscuits is supported by Rosetta Stone
now back when I was learning a language
I was a child I was just a me we we
little me self learning French you
didn't learn it too well in high school
and um now as an adult I would not want
to go back into that type of environment
because I don't think I would be allowed
to learn a language right but I bet you
there's a better way yes Here Comes
Rosetta Stone the most trusted language
learning program that truly immerses you
in the language you want to learn
they've used trusted experts for 30
years with millions of users in 25
languages offered like Spanish French
German Korean Japanese Arabic and polish
just a name a few and it's built for
fast language acquisition by immersing
you in many ways there are no English
translations so you really learn to
speak listen and think in that language
not to mention the built-in true accent
feature that gives you feedback on your
pronunciation it's like having a
personal trainer for your accent Rosetta
Stone is super convenient having desktop
and app options with audio companion and
ability to download lessons offline and
it's an amazing value a lifetime
membership has all 25 languages for any
and all trips or language needs in your
life it's a
$299 program but when you use our code
you can get it for just
$179 don't put off learning that
language there's no better time than
right now to get started for a very
limited time you can get Rosetta Stone's
lifetime membership for 40% off that's
$179 for unlimited access to 25 langu
anguage courses for the rest of your
life redeem your 40% off at
rosettastone.com
today we're going to talk about our
cereal uh and it's also the thing that
we're going to show to you right now so
you can know where you can go and get a
little taste of it if you want now I'll
just say it now so we don't forget eat
Mish mash.com that's the website where
you can this is basically DTC direct to
Consumer right the consumer maybe at
some point
end up on sh
somewhere I mean we can only hope for
that but really we just want it to end
up in your bowls so you can enjoy it uh
we got two flavors sweet Mac and mellow
which is not cheese flavored looks a box
of mac and cheese we thought that was
cool we thought that was cool you know
we're a little bit weird the first pasta
people have sex to our show cereal
ever uh as far as we know it is the
first past past shaped cereal it just
tastes like good sweet cereal with some
sweet marshmallows it's lovely but why
make one when you can come out of the
gate with twoo strong and complimentary
yet
distinct cereal flavors peanut butter
and honey sandwich we call it mish mash
because mish mash is like it's a it's a
fun and unexpected mixture this is
something that we do in when it comes to
mythical Foods a lot on the show lot of
unexpected combinations we're
curious and um yeah so putting mac and
cheese in a cereal is quite a mish mash
peanut butter and honey is a tried and
true mish mash from our childhood but we
had never had a cereal that combined
those two flavors right and in our
research it had not been done maybe we
didn't research enough but it's not
being done right now except by us right
we invented these just like we invented
Yol meal well no this is more
significant be call there's already a
mishmash cereal that even voicemails
well I have sex to your cereal SC we're
screwed I have sex with your cereal uh
we we don't need to hear about that we
don't need to hear about that as long as
you the box does double as a game not
just cool stuff on the back well the
back is actually a illustration of what
you could do when you have the box and
you unfold it both of these turn into
two different games that you can play
with the
cereal
uh but let's talk a little again eat
Mish mash.com but let's talk about some
of the unexpected things that you run
into when you're developing a cereal
welcome to serial development 101 it's
9:00
a.m. uh sir you're already sleeping not
cool
um we're two professors I was going to
talk we do not have an overhead
projector or a lesson plan so we may
talk over each other fairly regularly I
can't figure out how to get this smart
board to
work smart board as link said as Prof as
Professor Neil said uh we you know a lot
of people who are in our position you
know make YouTube videos and get the
opportunity to do other cool stuff like
make products um they tend to have
companies approach them and then they
say things like hey we've got a cereal
that we've already develop would love
you to call it R link cereal or mythical
cereal or whatever and you know us well
enough to know that that's not how we do
things around here at mythical yeah it's
not fun it's not fun are you okay you
going to are you going to make really
are you going to make it you are hurting
uh you just let it out just just hack it
out do you need some cereal there you go
because we can just boy that is crunchy
we can just throw some macaroni cereal
sounds like granola is coming out of
your lungs right now oh my god did you
have some water go down the wrong pipe
no I'm okay I'm okay what
happened
um I don't
know to be completely honest I feel like
doubled over yeah like something just
the spirit of the cereal joined my body
before I was ready well wow you're still
crying if you need to you you're you're
you're crying you're a bre you're
clearly dying but we got a show to do so
can you wait to
die this is over yeah hold on let me
postpone okay I think need to
just just you know rattle the
lungs get the CO all out here on
everybody I did take multiple Co tests
not Co I do have a little smidge of
bronchitis oh okay okay so you you're
actually sick don't don't be embarrassed
be proud not contagious I have a
doctor's note in my car you're now the
object of all all of our
ridicule this is our way of caring for
you Jamie I love it keep keep it coming
no just get back to cereal maybe
uh good God was like it sounded sharp
when it came up well let's move away
from the coughing back to the cereal I
don't want people to make too much of a
connection between for doing those two
things don't call it crunchy cough
crunchy if you hack up our cereal it
tastes just as good the second time um
so as I was saying
class you could just put your name on a
cereal we didn't want to do that we
wanted to develop a cereal from the
ground up cuz that more fun yeah we
thought well it f we wanted to innovate
we were kind of like ah if we're going
to do something like this which it makes
sense in in one sense for us to make a
Serial we have a Morning Show going on
12 years you know a lot of people enjoy
their breakfast while they watch Good
Mythical Morning so makes sense proceed
with caution on that front Link's a huge
cereal guy he cereal at all times of the
day um oh yeah I highly recommend mostly
at night this point at this point though
my observ mostly at night usually it's
your last meal
yeah yep and I had some last night so
right before I went to bed so the
general idea was develop something that
looked like something we would have
enjoyed as kids but it's something that
we can enjoy now and also I mean kids
are going to like it too but we
developed it for ourselves and our taste
buds and we tasted a lot of cereal I
mean as it was being developed it would
it would always show up in these like
these containers now we actually poured
out of this container now I mean this is
not the most appetizing of containers so
it's like we're pouring little bits into
bowls and like we're sitting in a
conference room like tasting cereal well
sometimes it would show up in bags I'm
like first of all I was like I've made
it I am professionally tasting cereal
Jamie's going to Jamie's going to take a
break you're just going to leave it's
fine we're good we're good everything's
rolling it's all automatic she's got
She's Gotta she's got really let it out
see if we can hear her oh she'll be
fine hacking up along she'll be fine we
tasted so many different types of pasta
cereals that were custom made just for
us well the thing is is that big pastas
little when we had the idea to do the
macaroni shaped
cereal we didn't know anything about
this they were like uh well first of all
the company that we were working with
wasn't expecting us to go so hard and be
like we're going to request a whole new
shape of cereal and they were like well
they have to make the machine like the
extruder right that then makes the
cereal because you're going to make this
stuff on mass right so and that's that's
where the price it gets pricey when
you're having to create tooling and
there was like questions do you really
want to do this and we were like well
yeah we like yeah we do yeah pasta so
cereal so you'll see when you get one of
these uh macaroni shaped jump it out but
actually
um actually these are this is not it is
not this is these are the ones that look
like dicks yeah yeah we it's funny again
the ones that are coming to you are a
little bit different than this because
this is actually just a tasting batch
that we had because there's so many
things like these are the ones that came
out and then the extruder would have a
little bit of bulge on the end and so
they kind of look like a a phus well
with with a little ball sack on the end
they taste good T and they but the thing
I was getting at is that these things
are Hollow because we could have done
them not Hollow but we wanted to do them
Hollow because macaroni is hollow so you
can literally take these and slurp up
milk or spit out milk do we even have we
actually don't have there's none of the
marshmallows in this either because
not only do we taste all types of pastas
we tasted all types of marshmallows big
ones little ones fluffy ones crunchy
ones and
interesting so the place where the
cereal was made and a lot of these
facilities are like this was a kosher
facility
right
and marshmallows are not
Kosher but something called marbit which
I don't I'm not 100% sure that we ended
up using exactly marbit but so when you
eat lucky charm a marshmallow in Lucky
Charms like a cereal marshmallow is not
a regular marshmallow cuz if you put a
regular marshmallow in milk which we
tried yeah to see what would happen you
do that and see what happens it's like
already a little bit mushy but what you
want is you want the crunch of that
little marshmallow those marshmallows
and like Lucky Charms it's so satisfying
a totally different thing to soak up a
little bit of milk and that doesn't have
to have the gelatin in it that makes it
non- kosher so I don't know I feel like
we learned a whole lot but we tasted
like four different types of
marshmallows landed on the size the
texture the shape I do feel like I was
living my dream you know as much as I
love being a cereal consumer being a
cereal developer was I don't know this
this is like a milestone moment for me
especially because the peanut butter and
honey sandwich was like very dear to my
heart so when we started developing what
that would look and feel like there was
the cinnamon toast crunch compon in
terms okay well they use toast pieces at
least it's it's supposed to look like
toast um and ours looks like a sandwich
in a different way but there was one
iteration the first iteration where it
was literally peanut butter and honey on
bread that was then chopped up
dehydrated yeah that's what I'm saying
and it's like a crouton almost and we're
like
this is well it tasted it tasted
incredible yes but as soon as you put
milk on it it turned to what bread yeah
turns into in milk it's like when I
would go down crunch to it to feed the
Ducks little pieces of bread and like if
they didn't eat bread real quick then
all of a sudden it was like a mushy mess
and so then the quest became to make a
piece of cereal that actually you know
was a piece of cereal that had a
consistency that would remain crunchy in
milk right that tasted like that
dehydrated peanut butter and honey
sandwich there's a difference in cons
there's a big difference in consistency
between these two uh they're so distinct
what do you mean consistency well uh the
peanut butter and
honey is that thing will stay really
really crunchy for you we did the crunch
test yeah and we determined which
cereals get soggy and it wasn't that the
better cereal stayed crunchy the longest
I mean in fact Cinnamon Toast Crunch
which is our number one best tasting
cereal and we did our full cereal
tournament right had a very very low
score in its lasting in because it got
soggy so quick yep so we wanted to have
a little bit of a spectrum M this one
the peanut butter and honey stays a
little bit crunchier the consistency of
the sweet Mac and mellow is it doesn't
stay crunchy as long as that but I kind
of feel like it creates a little bit of
spectrum I go back and fourth between
which one is my favorite consistency
wise yeah that's a good sign so try them
both out eat mm.com we're very proud of
what we've created here and uh we want
to know what you think oh and just so
you do you you uh you know
this class uh the mythical kitchen
spored multiple mythical employees were
also a part of the team in case you
think that
one or both of us have weird tastes
uh Josh and the team it was funny
because the way that Josh and Nicole
when they tasted the cereal like the
things that they say about it are like
culinarily informed right where we're
kind of just going completely on
Instinct that's why we got a good we got
a good team cover covering our bases and
it like we we covered a lot of bases and
we reduced certain
ingredients based on feedback and I
don't know we think you're going to love
it you're going to love one or the other
just like us
all right there's this thing on Twitter
that's happening that I don't know about
I was just
told that we should talk about the
yellow pillow debate well because we
have a little bit of a dog in this fight
or at least we have a history with this
so yeah this is the uh I've seen the
picture there was a
Twitter excretion and there was a uh
Tick
Tock video at least exre what you cuz
it's called X now that's what a that's
what a that's what a tweet's called now
is an
excretion oh uhhuh didn't know that
either well it's not true okay it's a
joke yeah I I I was almost about to know
that yeah yeah yeah and it's not my joke
I heard it somewhere and thought it was
funny oh H I don't remember who said it
wow um don't think it was worth
repeating yeah but it to me it helps
it's my way of commenting on the state
of Twitter when I call it an excretion I
don't have to go into the details of why
I think Twitter is an absolute show
now because of one particular person who
now owns it I don't have to actually go
into that I can just call it an
excretion and let it sit but thanks for
letting me explain it th this yeah sorry
that I I made you go through it and
since I've broke your concentration let
me go a little bit further and say that
like I can't help but notice that your
left eye is twitching like a mad dog oh
right here right yes yeah yeah yeah and
it makes you look very angry like you're
about to you're about it's like you're
about to lash out and like yeah I don't
know slap me or maybe punch yourself in
the face multiple times and get it
together get it together so it's
interesting because I noticed it
yesterday oh it was yesterday too yeah
this happens to me uh it's not a twitch
that I can feel like it doesn't you
don't feel it nope not all just look at
me I'll tell you yeah just happened just
happened just happened yeah I can't
there's no perception I can't see it do
you it's right there you don't have to
point it out I've seen it already what
can I I'm not pointing at it I'm trying
to touch it well you can no can I feel
that if I can feel the twitch with my
finger no see if you can feel it with
your finger I don't want you to touch my
face well then you touch your face and
see if you can feel the twitch
lightly lightly right
there cuz if it happens to me I can feel
it and it drives me crazy I get that too
that's not what this is in fact
yesterday when I looked into the mirror
before we shot I was like I saw it and I
was like oh that's weird I can my eye
has twitching but I can't feel it it's a
different muscle than it usually is I
think it's not it's too far away from
the eye to feel or something you might
need pottassium I have lots of potassium
I had a banana this morning well then
what's wrong well link the body is very
complex the human body is there's a lot
of things going on and sometimes things
like muscle twitches they call them um
like you know uh what do you call it
when there's no origin it's called Uh
there's a medical term for something
that is um oh gosh no one's going to be
able to say this like an anomaly there
is a my father-in-law used to say it all
the time it's a word for when they don't
know the source of something and it also
doesn't matter idiopathic idiopathic it
is a it is a twitch of idiopathic
origin at least as far as I know because
I'm an idiot that's just a fancy way of
saying you don't know why well I'm going
to say that I'm not are you concerned
for me is that what you're saying cuz
this is come and gone probably probably
a thousand times throughout my life and
I'm I'm still here and I'm
fine uh I was just expressing
concern well when you get a twitch in
your eye do you think something is wrong
yeah like I don't have enough potassium
maybe I need maybe I need a I'll have
another banana after this and maybe
it'll stop it stopped yesterday you you
don't want to talk about it well I'm
trying to talk about the thing that we
were going to talk about but I had to
explain why I don't like Twitter and now
I have to explain I don't like the
Twitch in my eye I'm have to explain why
I don't like twitch the the the that
platform too I think it's making you
testy man you're you're worried about it
don't we don't worry about it it's okay
I bet it'll just go away it's happened
to you a lot and it just goes
away that's where I was before that's
where I was before you mentioned it um I
mean it's a it's a relatively
unstructured show the fact that like
every time you look at me your eye looks
like it's about to well don't look at me
about to out of your skull all as a
concerned friend I just wanted to point
it out can you look at this eye so I'm
just not going to I'm not going to take
the L on this one you know I'm just I I
was did you know no one has to take an L
I'm saying I saw it but then you wanted
to touch it which is a little
intrusive want to touch it I asked
permission and I did touch it and then I
said I think I'm okay did you feel it I
didn't feel
it I think you might not feel like
you're okay and I'm making it course
forget I brought it up I feel like I'm
being gas
lit yeah it's hard to know what that
means okay well would you like me to
explain what gin means no see the last
five minutes of the
video okay would you like me to talk
about yellow
pillows tell me about the yellow pillow
okay so this was both a tweet and a Tik
Tok
and maybe people have stopped talking
about it by the time you're listening to
this but most of you probably don't know
about it um what did the Tweet say the
Tweet said basically finally showed my
girlfriend
the uh the yellow pillow girlfriend is
mad at me because I have revealed to her
the yellow pillow fellas I'm sure you
all know that this thing is Magic
there's no pillowcase on
it well I assume there is a pillowcase
normally I think that's what he did was
like he was taking the pillowcase off
and he showed it to his
girlfriend and it's
disturbingly stained is what I would
call it like stained with it's like a
tartter color so it's a white pillow but
not anymore so interesting so when you
see this you don't immediately like have
you don't I mean I've never had a pillow
this yellow let me start there but
you've never had a pillow with any
yellow on
it uh not that I've noticed no I mean
when I went to like my grand house even
as a kid and looked at they had some old
ass pillows and like I I would notice
that they were very
yellowed it's like a smoker slept on
them so it's you know it's a combination
of
sweat skin cells that some people say
dust mites Body Oil face oil lots of
yeah oil yeah for sure
so I you know I have a a wonderful wife
who
um noticed pretty early on in our
marriage
that my side of the
bed both the pillow and the
sheets and it we could like brand new
sheets after a certain number of
months maybe weeks you could tell which
side I was sleeping on like the sh of
Turin because yep just like the Shroud
of Turin because I am an oily man you
know I have oily skin my kids have oily
skin so the same thing happens with them
it's like it's not sweat I don't sweat
when I sleep like I don't have a
sweating thing it's just you know my my
you you see my face is oily my whole
body is oily and so it
like and I probably should sleep
probably should sleep with a t-shirt but
I don't it would probably help but it's
just like I'm like ah
whatever so it's your bed do what you
want I can relate to that part of it but
do you consider it magic no I consider
it nasty and also yeah I don't
understand what the
because it's yellow because of that
came off of your body and went into it
it didn't doesn't doesn't make it better
it makes it worse like objectively worse
maybe he feels like it's
seasoned like for a pillow to have
gotten that yellow he's had it a while I
think there's a magical quality to it
being completely broken in and he's
totally accustomed to
it and so maybe that's it's an
indication of a magic that's not
directly related to the oil I don't like
a a pillow that has lost its structure
either well you know me in my pillow I
have like a a a torture pillow it's a
cylinder torture pillow stuff with seed
husks yeah you're in a different place
with your pillow right now um but I did
buy a um a cover for it after using it
for a while because I realized uh
there's probably some stuff seeping into
this well there was an because of this
there were a number of Articles
written experts were like this is it's
actually bad bad for you it's bad for
your respiratory system like when your
pillow has that much stuff on it you
need to get rid of it which brought me
back
to um my favorite pillow the song that
we wrote in 2008 which has nothing to do
with the my pillow guy definitely not
like it preceded him and it had not my
favorite pillow is just the name of a
song it was sleep
better. org yeah they were they were
selling mattresses in pillows and they
wanted to sponsor a video and that was
back when we were um we said okay tell
us what you do they said well it's
mattress and pillows but it's also a
website where you can get educated on
these things that's why it was like
a.org so it's like Education portal to
selling a mattress our whole song My
Favorite pillow if you listen to the
lyrics the entire song is about this
concept that this excretion is about
yeah and it is designed to grow you out
enough to buy a new pillow all the
things that are in your pillow your
favorite pillow well you need to get a
new one because it's actually bad for
you I don't remember all the lyrics but
we did dust mites we did dustmite poo we
I we skin cells yeah uh and I think they
did recommend every six months but of
course I mean they're it was kind of a
fear campaign let's be real we were part
of a fear campaign we also got them to
ship us a tractor trailer load of their
pillows 600 of
and yeah it came in a tractor trailer
yeah and then we we made a pile of them
and jumped off the roof of our studio
backwards and forwards 600 Pillows it
wasn't the greatest song but it was the
greatest video because it was all in
Reverse yeah well we threw a lot at
that that yeah it was a different time
yeah it was a different
time uh I wonder if sleep.org is still
around I bet you I bet you they're
thriving um there still they're still
riding that that wave of R link video if
they are they are okay well that you you
know what go there for all your you know
used to be a sponsor used to be a
sponsor we don't have to say not a
sponsor there you go um yeah so I can
relate to it but I I do not let things
get to that point I love the fact that
somebody tweeted a like a picture of
their pillow and then they were
like doctors and Specialists writing
articles response to it it's the
internet machine it's the world we live
in man well but here's the thing we
could believe the best about these
doctors and I do believe the best about
doctors and experts but
really everyone who's putting any kind
of content on the Internet is looking
for a reason for somebody to click on it
so when somebody makes a big deal about
the yellow pillow yeah it's like oh okay
I can jump on this and I can offer my
little piece about
it still still about the clicks man yeah
I'm just saying the Tweeter the the
excrement or whatever you want to call
him he didn't know that was going to
happen no it's kind of I think that
that's it's a cool
phenomenon and hopefully you got a new
pillow out of it I mean he's probably
catching hell about it I mean I I talked
about how I don't wash my legs every
time I take a shower and I got caught
hell for
that good
I feel guilty if I skip leg day that's
what I call leg day when I watch my
legs well this is close I get leg day
but is leg day every day leg day is
supposed to be every day supposed to be
but some there have been days I well I
got a new loofah that doesn't hold as
much sud so by the time I get to my legs
I'm out of Suds because I got I got a
silicone loofah and I jury still I don't
know whether I like it or not but I
think I do okay I got got it
because the I got annoyed with the
amount of time it took for me to squeeze
all or as much as I could the suds out
of the LOF and when I was done with it
and that was adding time to my shower
that was annoying to me and so I'd been
advertising some
silicon fancy schmancy lofas I was like
I'm going to try one of those because
they can be rinsed quickly what about
the what about the actual plant loofah
you've never dealt with this
I don't feel like it's a great
performer okay yeah it's very
scratchy and it's not that permeable so
it doesn't actually have a lot of
suds but thanks for asking I've
definitely thought about all this
H let's get to another one um should we
talk about my fanny pack I mean I know
I've rode you the wrong way this is a
chance for you to you to you let me have
you talking about your fanny pack is
really going to make it's really going
to help right you just had you've had an
enough of me today no no I'm happy about
your fanny pack it's very here's the
thing your wife uh has confided in my
wife
about uh how often you lose things right
there was a point of
concern um I have Geo tags on a lot of
my most important things now and so I
think given the fact and I wouldn't say
that I lose them I would say I misplace
them because I always find them and it
was where I had placed it and IID just
forgotten that I placed it there and I
think that's what she's really concerned
about not that I lose things I forget
where I placed them it's not just
misplacing uh but it isn't uncommon for
us to arrive at a place where an ID is
required and you don't have your wallet
yeah that happens 40% of the time that
we show up a place where an ID is
required there you go I don't like
carrying my wallet in my pants pocket
because when I sit down then I have to
move it to the front pocket then when I
stand up I have to move it to the back
pocket because I don't like how it looks
in the front pocket and yes it's the
it's a lowprofile thin wallet but it's
still more than a wallet I have on the
other ass cheek so they're not level and
it
bothers me so you know what I do I don't
carry my wallet I leave it in my car
need it who needs it I leave it in my
car a lot of times that's smart and uh I
didn't say it was smart I just say I did
it and I'm not saying any of this is
smart I'm just saying but given the
situation that we find ourselves in
losing my keys but also uh you have you
need more things than the average man
that I've have associated with on on my
in my life I
I am in touch with what I like to have
okay with me okay and uh I'm a self- pre
I like to have things that optimize my
experience and without in it having a
negative impact on anybody else right so
that is one of my questions is like is
the fact that I am I'm in a test period
with what I'm I'm going to unabashedly
call a fan pack here it is right
here it's got a llama on it it's not a
sponsor but uh I was I was you know for
a trip coming up I was looking for some
bags and boy
why I I finally started to get like my
mother-in-law has an obsession with
purses and I started to feel a
connection to her when I started looking
at all these bags on the internet
there's bags of all sizes that drape in
all types of places all over your body
that hold all types of things and
they're super specialized and awesome
and there's stories to go along with it
and so here I am in this world of bags
putting bags and bags and all types of
bags in my cart well so what do you have
in this bag well I will say that I
bought another fanny pack that became
the dog walking fanny pack it's got room
for uh all the dog walking stuff
and it's all there and I strap on the
the fanny pack and it's got the treats
and it's got the uh the poop bag and
it's got a water bottle holder that I
use to actually hold the the U the full
poop bags of which I had three this
morning give me a freaking break but
this is my daily
life linkx self-preservation bag okay so
what's let's let's open it up if you
pull this right here
it turns into one of those rafts that
goes into the ocean that has a rooftop
on it lital preservation and I can stay
in it for like
a a couple
weeks um there's a number of well you
know first of all there's I mean there's
there's the obvious I've got you know
got my wallet here and um next to my
wallet lip balm okay I mean I can't tell
you the amount of times that I've been
somewhere and I've just needed lip balm
and I hav't had it of course I have my
keys on a they're on a thing that they
can never fall out okay and then I have
my my uh headphones my airpods here okay
right down there I have a um a Geo
Tracker mhm when I lose all of this
inevitably it's tracked I also have one
of those on the keys I also have one of
those in the wallet so now I don't if
any of it falls out I can track it
independently I've got an I've got some
almonds might need some nuts
um and in here let's see where should I
go next there's so many openings that's
part of the fun of this thing um
sunglasses like these right here it's
always nice to have a pair of sunglasses
that I can also read with these are
these are reading SL sunglasses I can't
drive with them because they make me
sick okay but I've got those in here I
mean I can't tell you how many times you
might need that sometimes usually I'll
have my phone in this part of it I'm
experimenting with even keeping my phone
in here how do you know if the phone's
ringing um my phone doesn't ring if it
rings I don't answer it that's not what
I do with my
phone okay so that why is why you never
answer the phone or text uh I'll text
sometimes but it's usually on do not
disturb I I know you said that I here I
added you to the exception to do not
disturb so that I wouldn't annoy you
anymore by not being undis trying to be
undisturbed I let you break through
every time and um you w me up from a
couple of naps so I I put you back on
the uh do not call list there's a 74
there's nobody there's a 74% chance that
if I text him during the weekend he will
be napping I I know I'm not easy to live
with but it's all about
boundaries with where I stop and you
start you know okay uh here's my backup
yeah I will not start carrying a fanny
pack just in case you're wondering a
backup pair of headphones even if you
stop I will start I really don't need
these in there they're in there because
um it makes me feel more secure if I'm
on a plane you got to have headphones
that plug in very important I have
medication um this is uh
herpes breakout medication in if I feel
like if I can feel one coming on I break
out one of these pills and they're
beautiful pills these are some of the
most beautiful drugs I've ever taken
looks like Legos I mean look at that
those
are look can you see it um herpes pills
are the most beautiful drug I've ever
take MH they're like a deep
blue um almost look like a vitamin but
it looks fake it looks they look fake
They look fake and they're so huge it
might just be plastic and you just
them right out unaltered I take two of
them at a time too I only need those
like once a quarter so interesting that
they're in the fanny pack but go keep
keep going I'm building a list of
questions the moment that you H that you
sense that you have a cold sore breakout
is the moment you need to take this and
you can't be like oh it's at home well I
got to get home now I'm actually going
to start carrying caffeine pills in here
too great that way I'm not see I'm not
going to insist on hey guys I know we're
doing something else but can we stop
what it we're doing and so I can go get
a coffee like I don't want to be that
guy so caffeine pills okay um I have
this spray bottle to clean my glasses
and a couple of these uh glasses ready
cleaners and um you know I went out with
my friends the other night it was the
first time I took this thing out in
public and to um Stave off the potential
ridicule and puzzlement I offered to
clean everyone's sunglasses in the Uber
oh that was sweet of you and you know
what I was I was the
hero uh here's some pain
reliever here's a
USB here is a another thing of lip balm
which is classic the
classic um you know it seems a bit
bottomless to be honest with you one
Band-Aid you don't need to care you
don't need more than one at a time uh
and then of course you know back here um
I've got a couple of pictures like a
couple of pictures of my family yep
great and then I have um stack of
fluorescent Post-it notes and well um a
pen and you can't take notes on your
phone of course and then um well maybe
if I need a leave a note like sorry I
dinged your car yep well you're very
prepared uh and a highlighter and
um there you have it and you know what
and I'm and I don't wear it I don't wear
it like a fanny pack I wear it as a
sling pack I think that's what I felt
comfortable doing is just wearing it
over my over my shoulder you know this
is this is a this is acceptable this is
I mean look I'm just I'm just a guy
walking around just a guy I'm just a guy
walking around with a with a pack maybe
maybe maybe I'm a photographer maybe
there's a camera in here okay I have a
just just a few observations I'm not you
know I'm not going to take any cheap
shots
um okay just one thing just so you that
you should be prepared I'm not going to
make fun of you for this but I do want
you to know that if you ever have a
spontaneous like rap battle breakout and
you're on one side of it this will be
the focus of your all your takedowns
yeah everything the person wraps about
beated to your fanny P just so you
understand that and the crowd will go
wild every time the guy comes back to
fanny pack too easy you think you might
use the term man purse it's too easy of
a Target and I'm not going to stoop to
that level I wouldn't do that thank you
um also say has these cinch things on
the side that like I can I it's
expandable but also it's contractable
yeah I mean because you might need even
more things in there um
right questions legitimate questions
sure yeah I'm I'm an open book
um so essentially if you're committing
to wearing a bag at all
times okay which is again um
approximately half of the population
already does this right probably right
right but a lot of guys are are starting
to carry and a lot of women don't little
bags Stevie doesn't a purse never has
never seen her with a bag of any kind
um but people who carry bags at all
times have they can't carry one bag all
the time you have to have multiple bags
because it has to complement what you're
wearing oh no does it not well yeah I
kind of thought that you know it's khaki
I thought it was pretty versatile I'm
not saying it's not versatile the last
thing I'm going to do is I'm start
transferring everything from my my my
bag to another bag depending on what it
needs to match so okay but I think that
maybe and this is something that the
difference between a self- pressed
person and a nonself I thought about I
thought about getting a totally black
one the difference between a self-
pressed person and a non-self pressed
person I think lip balm is actually a
microcosm by which you can map a lot of
things are there times when I could use
Li bomb mhm well of course I have lips
mhm and I don't think that my lips are
substantially different than your your
lips well right I think they
are well I think that my guess is yours
aren yours on a herpes Factory okay
right right right but let's take the
herpes out let's throw the blue pill out
for a second well the lip balb is is
like a preventative measure I'm just I'm
not I'm not trying to make a sob story
here but like okay so that's why you use
lip
balm I also really like
it but what I'm saying is that self
press like lip balm is a common thing
that self pressed people have because
there are probably there's probably a
not insignificant percentage of the time
in which I could use lip balm like if
you look at my lips and you're like you
know you could like if I'm getting uh if
Anna is doing makeup for us for
something we don't do makeup for GMM we
don't have somebody who does it for us
but we used to and like when we shoot
things that are different like and we
have somebody they they always offer lip
balm sometimes I say okay but then
sometimes I'm like no because I do at
least maybe I'm wrong about this but my
perception of lip balm is that once you
start using lip balm you kind of need to
keep using lip balb because your lips
are kind of expecting the bomb right
maybe whether I'm right or wrong that's
just kind of that's my operating
philosophy so if you take lip balm and
you map it on to I might need this and
therefore I should have
it that self- pre and so you end up with
a fanny pack and then the other half of
the population is like I might need it
but I probably won't so I'd rather not
have it and I'd rather just have the
things that I need which is my wallet
which has ID credit cards and my phone I
don't carry
keys because my car doesn't require a
key that's what about house key okay I
so there's a number of things that you
have in bag that I keep in my backpack
which I have with me basically anytime I
go out to work or I travel yeah right I
did take this on a date so that was my
next question is like okay so you've got
the question of I did ask first I was
like it was a casual date if I was
really dressed up we're going somewhere
nice I would not have done this but so
that's my that was my next question is
like you know the a the average woman
who gets dressed dressed up and has a
purse with her that purse is a fashion
statement sometimes the biggest fashion
statement that she's making yeah at a
formal event right right and so I'm
assuming that you're not going to carry
bags to formal events or like when you
get dressed up and you go but maybe
maybe though because are you opening the
door to that I think I must be because
in those situations I'm still like
Christy can you put my sunglasses in
your in your bag
and this lip balm and can you carry the
keys and by that point it's like well
she can't fit anything in her bag she's
just carrying a bag for me and at that
point you have but I think the thing
that for me is like I don't want to have
a I just don't want to have to think
about a
bag in those scenarios I'd rather not be
responsible for a bag because uhuh if
you lose that bag you lose everything
yeah and that's a scary thing have you
thought about that I'm not saying you
shouldn't do this I'm just saying yeah
I'm I going to lose the whole bag these
are the reasons that I'll never the
first reason I'll never get to the point
is because I honestly don't find myself
needing anything besides these two
things and the things that I have in my
bag when I travel I've got the same
exact two pairs of headphones that you
have I've got Advil in case I get a
headache I got all that stuff there's a
lot of stuff that I didn't need I could
have gotten a smaller bag but since the
bag was so big I just I cleaned out my
laptop bag and I put everything in it
that's why there's like Post-it notes in
here this also is coinci it's also
coinciding with filling the space I have
it's coinciding with another thing that
you've been pushing for which is
complete dismissal of the laptop yes
that's my goal is to never open a laptop
so this is why you don't answer or send
emails well I'm just not good at it it's
not my it's not my strength so I'm like
I hate it I AB absolutely hate it like I
cannot stand but they're much harder to
send on phone
writing Communications I don't like you
know I don't Tex I don't but here's the
thing text and slack and
email I do all three of those
primarily on my laptop so yeah because I
don't like I just don't I don't like
thumbing it man it's you know there's
too many typos I might be going audio
only there's a lot of people who do that
you know people you know people are
doing that uh we have a friend who only
S Audio messages a couple actually and
I'm like maybe this is my future I'm an
audio message guy you know I get worried
about The Crafting of the message oh I
want to say that a little bit
differently yeah I haven't started to do
it yet I'm I'm quite the verbal
processor probably be doing a couple and
then only sending the last one so the so
the lack of need to begin with but then
this the the two things for me is
like having to worry about a bag from a
fashion standpoint and also a I got a
bag with me now those two things this
work all my casual stuff yeah I think I
it's it's an experiment at this point
but I've decided to fully commit to it
and then we'll see where it
goes I would say that it's beneficial to
have a friend who has a bag mhm um so I
would just my only request is that I
might have some things I need you to put
in the bag yeah I might have to get rid
of some Post-it notes well it's
expandable I mean you already made the
point it's expandable yeah I had I had a
a full water bottle in it yesterday too
so sure sure um but again I'm not going
to make fun of you but I will let you
know that a
street uh freestyle rapper would crucify
you for that just just I wouldn't get
into any rap battles and if you if you
sense a rap battle a sense a rap battle
coming on toss toss the fanny pack as
far away from you as possible at that
point it doesn't matter who ends up with
it where your stuff is you don't want to
get completely burned in a rap battle
yeah I'm probably then taking my shirt
off too just to like I wouldn't do that
add a little Whimsy to it okay how far
is this guy G to go to give on their he
don't give them more
material I will say for people watching
this who could see your bag there
there's going to be comments of people
saying that it it's a crossbody bag it's
a cross body bag yeah cuz I'm holding it
cross body but it can be there's quite a
few rappers who Embrace crossbody bags
like yeah ASAP ASAP Rocky I've seen him
but not freestyles not freestyle rappers
well she's you is a freestyle rapper let
her finish I think he's done some
but in a freestyle rap he would drop the
bag I'm just telling you you don't want
to Fumble the bag they also wear chains
which um those are good to have you
might need to add a chain I'm really
that might completely offset it speaking
speaking of anything that you know I'm
anything else
to you know it's it's it's it's the
future I think it it could be the future
for all people yeah to have a bag is it
nice to have a bag with everything you
need why why is it that only women can
have bags well you know Society speaking
like well well um because women didn't
have pockets for so long because women
couldn't have possessions so you didn't
so women's clothing never had pocket
because we weren't allowed to have
possessions and it so like then purses
came in because well you can't give
women Pockets cuz then what are they
going to do that that it'll mess up the
silhouette fun um no uh we love Pockets
um it's just too many men make um uh
garments I but I hate Pockets see and if
you hate Pockets then perfect pockets
are for hands when hands are cold mhh
and if you but if you have like utility
pants I do have pants with lots of
pockets you do but then I don't like to
put things in them because then when
they're like I get like leg flap and I
don't know flap this is so much better
this is so much better so okay point
taken pocketbooks as I call
them uh I don't know why I call them
well you think yeah I mean think about
someone in a dress pocketbooks are no
place to put anything you got to you got
to have a bag you might our fingers our
fingers have evolved to be able to carry
um much more than we possibly could in
one hand and I will say alsoa
traditionally women are you know more
often than not and traditionally women
are wearing makeup men are or not and so
you've got you've got some makeup for
touch-ups and stuff you've got feminine
products a lot of times there's there's
more things traditionally that you would
need to have with you and then you don't
have pockets taser yeah whole whole
gamut so and that kind of makes sense
I'm listen I'm not against a man purse
and I have considered a man purse as my
laptop bag but my like a a shoulder bag
yeah but my thinking
is everything that you have your fanny
pack I have in my laptop bag and I'm
actually leaning into laptop right now
I'm doing much less phone and more
laptop see the thing for me is like that
scramble to grab everything and make
sure you have it all I don't have that
problem anymore I just grab the one
thing and I know that everything's in it
because everything's always in it and
now I always have my wallet with me I
always have everything that I should
have had with me but I didn't because I
didn't take the time like okay the keys
go in the front pocket the wallet goes
in the back pocket pocket phone goes in
the other pocket maybe I'll throw in the
lip balm in the pocket and then oh where
are my post notes going to go you know
it's like it's I've
knocked five sometimes 15 minutes if I
have to start searching for something
something that's not been lost off every
morning yeah it's all there pick it up
go it's a go bag the big question is the
is going to be the ID because if you've
got your wallet in
there uh and you cuz you're probably not
going to take that to usually the place
where you don't have your ID is when we
go to some sort of event where we're
dressed up in a in like a fancy way yeah
I know I'll figure it out so that's the
only question just because that always
ID should be on the phone I mean it
really should it just should be a
thing yeah I mean well just like your
credit cards is now in your phone you
could your ID your real ID should be in
your phone well you could also just get
one of those cases that just has a slip
for for your
ID yeah but not like all your credit
cards just where's the lip balm going to
go on the side and
Holster maybe you could do everything
that you've got going on there just on a
phone with holsters
passport I bought this for travel and
then I backed into Everyday Use so we'll
see how it goes I'll give you a much
shorter fashion update uh as I continue
to experiment my you know my
experimentation is being is loafers at
this point so that's I'm not doing Fanny
pack but I am doing loafers and uh and I
can't do that so there you go that's
where you can do and I start you can do
it if you want why don't you think you
can I already told you you're not going
to do it because I did it no but you
just don't think you can do it yeah it's
not okay it won't work for me because if
I decide to get a fanny pack it what I'm
saying is if I get a fanny pack everyone
will like I don't think you haven't
boxed me out of fanny packs I don't
think so because two men with two fanny
packs
could be an Unstoppable force in fact if
a r battle started you're coming to my
side here's come on over here's the
thing you could keep your loafers in the
pack well I'm going to tell you about
something that goes in loafers that I
could keep in there if a rap battle
starts and the two of us are on one side
of the rap
battle we both keep the fanny packs
because if we have power and numbers and
we can use when every time that pair
that's arguing that's rapping against us
tries to do a fanny pack line we use it
against them it's harder to do by
yourself is all I'm saying okay yeah so
as you know the loafers that I got the
first time had that mock toe I wanted to
get another
pair that had more of a traditional
profile um you've done it so I got these
and I wore these for a couple of days to
break them in I enjoyed them quite
thoroughly I did notice because they did
not have the mock toe that they were not
as comfortable as the as as the other
ones I don't what tell me what a mo is
again I've heard that called it's short
for moccasin oh you know where it's like
basically like a and I may be using it
wrong but it's basically like when
there's a wall that goes straight up and
then there's a knit that goes around I
around and it gives more room for the
toes likely to scrape and stuff but the
thing about this one is that it had this
insole this leather insole and I was
like it's basically a a low a Loa for
it's a boot looks like a the start of a
boot it's the start of a boot it could
be it could have continued to be become
a boot and um this is more traditional
this is a more traditional loafer so um
as I wore them I was like I kind of feel
like I'm I'm sweating a bit more in
these so then I did a little research
turns out the thing that we overlooked
in
between no
socks and uh
baby
socks was just an an insert insole
that's basically a sock material what so
not a sponsor Dr scholes makes this
Terry claw thing oh that you just stick
down in there because 90% of the sweat
that might happen on your foot is coming
from the bottom of your foot so then you
take that out and launder it no it's
just it's it's odor resistant did that
do the yeah no no issue at all so
you can do this as well so Cherry cloth
insert and there's other ones this is
the first one that I found on Amazon and
I just took the I took the insole that's
built in out and held the thing up and
just cut it to match exactly then put
both of them back in there and I'm
having no problem you're like a damn
cobbler so I'm kind of a bit of a loafer
expert at this point yeah talking about
the M toe and the and I got to say I'm
really the thing that I'm really
enjoying about these speaking of
Silhouettes yeah is I just I I like the
way that it you got something going on
if you start looking at somebody from
head to
toe and you see what they've got on and
then it ends with a loafer mhm sends it
in a slightly different direction yeah I
agree with that you when you land on
tennis shoes it sends it in another
Direction don't get me wrong I'm still a
tennis shoot guy you could you could be
having like a marina meeting I do feel
like at any moment I could
like clap my hands one time and
then say something that sounds important
even if it
wasn't where I'm just saying I don't
know if you can do that in tennis shoes
I think you might be able to look out
and see a boat floating on the water but
it's not your boat they're not boat
shoes that's a different thing again
you're not on the boat I'm not a boat
shoe guy yet okay yeah you're going
these are loafers
yeah I'm just saying if I need to call
an impromptu meeting with one clap I
think I now have the ability to do that
tennis shoes you got to do three claps
and then you sound like you're just
clapping and and applauding something I
just don't I'm going to advise you
against clapping to get your way I've
never done it I'm just now that I've got
loers considering it don't uh-uh well
don't clap to get your but I feel like
now us as a pair you've got the fanny
pack clap you encourage so I don't know
if the fanny pack has increased your
um you know clap and get my way yeah I
don't know if it's increased or
decreased but I I think I've balanced it
out a little bit with my loafers
whatever whatever you've changed in the
dynamic in the way that we present as a
Duo yeah I think that your fanny pack is
to my loafers and we basically have sort
of returned to a nice yeah you know
Marina equinity I think I'm a little I
mean this is kind of granola this is
either forest or
Urban I don't know you got to have your
you got to have your stuff with you we
got it covered from the from the
mountains to the
ocean and
Beyond thanks for the voicemails you
really it's really helpful you know
getting your feedback uh so you know
what I welcome it 1888 earpod one I have
a wreck it is a musical wreck I love
musical recks I am going to ask you to
listen to a song okay called
honeybody all one word sounds good not
in celebration of our cereal uh but in
celebration of the artist Kishi Bashi
who I've I've been a fan of his for a
while he's uh I would call
him I think they basically people call
him like psychedelic pop
or Indie
pop he's a
multi-instrumentalist just musical gen
genius who does all kinds of different
music um but honeybody is like if you
just need to put yourself in a good mood
right now and you don't know how to get
into it and you just need a song to put
you in a good mood that's important play
honeybody by Kishi Bashi all right I've
added
it well I'm about to here we go I just
it talk at you next week bye hey ritten
link this is uh sleepy Dave you said to
leave a gentle voicemail at the end of
episode 400 so I
just I just thought I'd call in
andom
[Music]
finally to watch more earbiscuits click
on the playlist on the right to watch
the previous episode of ear biscuits
click on the playlist to the left and
don't forget to click on the cirular
icon to subscribe if you prefer to
listen to this podcast it's available on
all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical
best